plus de 2000 jours de paralysie
politique
l'irlande du nord dispose enfin d'une
nouvelle assemblée et d'un nouveau
gouvernement
les deux principaux partis du pays les
unionistes dudit youpi et les
républicains du chine féin ont validée
in extremis le projet d'accord visant à
rétablir les institutions politiques de
la province
l'assemblée locale a désigné hier la
chef du parti unioniste arlines foster
comme première ministre
la républicaine michele o'neal est pour
sa part nommé vice première ministre
ces trois dernières années ont été
dominés par trop de divisions et de
récrimination
le vrai travail commence aujourd'hui les
leçons ont été apprises il est temps de
permettre à l'irlande d'aller de l'avant
un scandale politico-financier avait
fait tomber la précédente coalition
gouvernementale en janvier 2017 et
plusieurs séries de négociations
n'avaient pas permis de surmonter le
conflit l'assemblée nord-irlandaise est
censé avoir son mot à dire sur les
dispositions douanières controversé
visant à éviter le retour d'une
frontière physique avec la république
d'irlande après le break it
l'annoncé de ce nouveau gouvernement a
réjoui le premier ministre irlandais
leo varadkar et le premier ministre
britannique boris johnson
alors que nous entamons nouvelle
décennie nous pouvons désormais espérer
un avenir meilleur pour tous en irlande
du nord avec un exécutif qui peut
transformer les services publics et
améliorer la vie des gens
tous les partis les politiques d'irlande
du nord doivent être félicités pour leur
décision de mettre le peuple qu'ils
représentent en premier est de faire des
compromis mesurer pour parvenir à un
accord pour la toute première fois lors
des élections législatives de décembre
la province a élu plus de députés
républicains partisan d'une
réunification avec l'irlande que d'une
yunist favorables à un maintien dans la
couronne britannique
or depuis 1998 l'accord de paix du
vendredi saint
les unionistes dudit youpi et les
républicains du chine féin doivent
obligatoirement se partager la
gouvernance de la province britannique
les deux partis avaient jusqu'à ce lundi
10 janvier pour s'entendre avant que
l'ombre de convoque de nouvelles
élections locales
l'accord a finalement été entériné par
les deux parties vendredi soir ce
compromis signés offre une
reconnaissance légale à la langue
irlandaise et prévoit d'accélérer le
actionnement de la justice ou encore des
mécanismes pour lutter contre la
corruption des investissements
concernant les services publics ont
également été promis par londres afin
d'aider la province la plus défavorisés
économiquement du royaume uni
[Musique]